on today's show we're going to be
talking about adult themes so watch out
for the little ears
in the room we're going to talk to a mom
whose 14 year old is struggling with
anxiety
we're going to talk to another young
woman whose mother
is always talking about suicide and
we're going to be talking with the new
young mom
who just found out that relatives
invited a sex offender to the holiday
season
and she wants to know what to do next
stay tuned
yo yo this is john and this is the dr
john deloney show
it's a show where we show up we walk
alongside
people who are struggling trying to
figure it out
who are trying to navigate the
post-election world
the current coveted world trying to
navigate
all of it it's just a mess and i wish
i'm an optimistic guy i it's a mess it
just is a mess
and it's going to take a whole bunch of
people deciding
to act a whole bunch more mature than we
have been
to make a whole bunch more better
decisions
right how we show up how we love people
how we let things go how we pardon and
forgive and how we say you know what
we got hosed on that one this one sucks
this one we got screwed this one we won
whatever and then say but cool i've got
to
put on my big boy pants my big girl
pants
and i got to go help my neighbor i've
got to actually lean into my school
district and help solve this deal
the coveted numbers are still going up
and up and up and i'm going to have to
possibly look at doing something
different whatever it is
there are so many people dealing with
relationship challenges
and parenting challenges and mental
health issues
all of it whatever is going on i'm here
for you
give me a call let's talk through it
let's help everyone make the next
right wobbly crooked step and on this
show we're going to talk about falling
in love
falling out of love we're going to talk
about loss we're going to talk about
family issues
and we're just going to stop the presses
for a second and we are going to give
a super shout out to every
teacher in every school district across
this country
trying to figure out how to not get sick
themselves
how to deal with their own homes their
own husbands their own wives their
own kids their own aging parents
how to teach your kid and let's be
honest
for the last five or six years if you've
been that parent who's like
my kid's just failing because they're
teacher you had to homeschool
now you know it's probably your kid it
was probably your kid that was the
weirdo
or the kid that doesn't pay attention
doesn't sit down in class maybe your
teachers weren't as bad or evil as you
thought they were
maybe they were right not everybody's
perfect but
i know many many many many many many
parents who have realized well my kid's
not quite the same that i thought they
were
and here's a teacher trying to figure
out how to have class with a room full
of third graders
both in person and on zoom and deal with
all of the parent communications and the
text messages and the emails
all of it and so i just want to take a
minute
and shout out to teachers you guys are
have got us through this fall you're
getting us to the
thanksgiving the christmas breaks you're
getting us on into the new year and i
just want to say
i'm so grateful for you if you know of
somebody who's a teacher
even if you don't if you don't have kids
at home anymore and you're listening to
this podcast
find some cookies find an arrangement
find it someone that you know that's a
teacher or
you that you know who knows who knows
somebody's a teacher and just reach out
and say thank you send them a note send
them a gift
just tell them you appreciate them
teachers have done their heroic duty
this fall
and it is just their heroism
day in and day out just astounds me and
i'm so grateful for them so whatever's
going on in your heart in your home or
in your head
i'm here let's do it give me a call at
eight four four
six nine three thirty two ninety one
that's one eight four four
six nine three three two nine one or
you can go we got a new show page up
it's johndaloni.com
show so go to johndaloni.com show
there's a web form where you can fill
out
what's going on and get on the show i'd
love for you to go there
johndeloney.com show looking forward to
it let's go straight to the phones let's
go to janelle
in wichita kansas janelle good morning
what's going on
good morning thanks for taking my call
thank you so so much how can i help
uh we have a 14 year old son that
struggles with
anxiety um it
he's kind of had off and on issues
seems like for it started like maybe
and janelle i'm losing you here
hello hey janelle are you back oh there
you are okay
so i missed that first part let's start
that over again so let me know what's
going on with
your with your little boy so you have a
14 year old who's struggling
yes he seemed like in about fifth grade
he kind of
just changed from uh
and so we started you know looking
medical was something going on and
we finally he's on anxiety medicine and
he just has such a struggle with feeling
like
like something's wrong with him and he's
it just almost discourages him
to take his medicine because we don't
we're kind of at a loss we
we don't know where to go with this sure
so let's go back to fifth grade
um did something happen during fifth
grade
was there some sort of um relational
issue that happened in home
was there something with your guy's
marriage did he have some trauma was he
abused somewhere what happened in fifth
grade
you know it was just we can't pin one
thing down that we know of he
we go to a small parochial school okay
and he they had the same teacher all day
he changed teachers
and she was a little more uh like
she she loved to have her students do
well she was not
mean and it stressed out is all we could
figure out
okay so um you've probably heard i
i whenever i hear the word anxiety when
a kid is struggling with anxiety
um i hear that as an alarm system and i
always want to look at his environment
what's going on in his ecosystem
um so if you think back to first second
third fourth was
was life pretty smooth back then um
were you and his dad on great terms does
he have older brothers and sisters
um was he just plugging along and then
suddenly fifth grade hit him like a like
a like a bus
or or or was there did you kind of see
this one coming when you look back
you know he when he was a baby he had
separation anxiety okay and i don't know
if that
connects but he got seemed like he got
over that and
for the first how long if there was
laughing that's where he was
just in just a title and i or have had
no issues
he has an older brother and a younger
sister
and you know i take some of the blame my
husband does we've
we've sometimes thought our oldest child
is
he works extremely well in a black and
white
environment this is right and this is
wrong and my husband's a little tender
that way not
meanly but it's just sensible to him
this was wrong do it this way and he
seems like he's struggled under that
we've tried to change
our approach sure
um and so what what about the nutrition
stuff what came back with his nutrition
test nothing
no celiacs no clear up
short of the scope i sometimes he just
yeah he doesn't sleep at night his
stomach hurts
i sometimes wish if we had a ton of
money i would just do all the tests
sure but we have a superb pediatrician
and he feels like
for now he needs to focus on you know
the protein
and just taking his meds but
he'll just cry this 14 year old boy
what's wrong with me so where does he
get the message
that there's something wrong with him
where does that come from
you know i don't know i
i am does it come from is it come from
his brothers and sisters does it come
from
you or your husband does it come from
the doctor what something about his
world
is letting him know i'm not normal and
i'm broken
well and this i don't want to sound like
this is this is not abusive or something
but
my husband works has to work very hard
on being
like i said he's a very black and white
person like
if you're in the mud you get out and
i've i've told him and he sees that you
know
have had that affected it
um it could frustrate him that
this boy is like come on yeah okay
so i i'm i'm
i'm hesitant right now to walk through
some potential
ideas and thoughts with you and i'm
gonna tell you why and this is me just
being honest and i want all the
listeners here in this
to know i'm i'm trying to navigate both
my interaction with you
and um a situation with a young man that
i'm not that's not sitting in front of
me right
i don't like parents who and i know it's
hard it's natural i'm a parent too
i don't like parents who default to
quote unquote blame
are there some things that you could be
doing differently possibly
are there things that your husband may
have contributed that you may have
contributed over the years
possibly and i would even go as far as
probably
but to then move that over to blame
whenever you go to blame
then you always have to have judgment
when you have judgment you got to have
um like a penalty and that's not helpful
with somebody who's struggling from
anxiety
that's not helpful with someone who's a
kid right
my mom was on the quote unquote cutting
edge of health
and nutrition stuff when i was a kid so
you know what that meant i ate
margarine and tab remember that drink
and crystal light bars and you couldn't
have found
a gram of fat in my home if you i mean
i mean it was it was nowhere right and
now all of the
science lets everybody know that that's
pretty much gonna kill us all that we
lived like that
right and so my mom did the best she
could with the information she had in
front of her in fact she went
overboard trying to love and care for
her family
it turns out the information she had was
incorrect right
and so i'm going to err on the side of
being honest with you
and i'm going to err on the side of just
throwing some things up against the wall
here because again i'm not talking to
your son
could a black and white father who looks
at his son and says get over it
collapse his hands a few times and says
hey let's go could that contribute to a
young man who's hurting
yes dads
often and i'm one of them want to just
solve problems we want to quote unquote
fix people in our lives as though they
were mechanical objects
i just need to change this sprocket i
just need to fix
this spark plug and then they will work
again and that's not how people work
a great great cornerstone gift
a father can give to his son is a is
daily hugs
every day every day and not just passive
side hugs
but i'm talking full chest to chest
squeeze hugs and then whispering in your
son's ear
i love you and i'm proud of you and
letting that just
be that has a way of calming and healing
children from the inside out and your 14
year old may be tall maybe big maybe
going to high school
but he's still a child and here's the
thing moms too
and sometimes when moms get
uncomfortable around their kids when
they are dealing with things like
anxiety they don't want to
hurt the kid and so they end up backing
out
they don't want to say the wrong thing
they don't want to give the wrong
impression
and it just creates a wider and wider
gulf
and so the greatest gift you could give
your child right now
is not more information you're working
with a doctor and so do what the doctor
is suggesting
and i don't have the doctor in front of
me to ask him questions about
anxiety and high fats diets
and anxiety and like i said limited
protein and limited
grains and sugars and things like that
every kid is different he's looked at
your son's blood
test in particular and so we're going to
go with what your doctor is saying right
now
the greatest gift you can give your son
is
undivided connection
every day do you squeeze your son and
you may have been doing that right
you may have been well it's kind of
ironic because
that boy will literally he always just
wants to be scratched his back and his
arms like he'll crawl in my lap he's 14.
yeah i realize maybe
it's a comforting thing to him
i've just yeah i'm not a touchy person
so this is
a good thing to think about when uh when
your anxiety alarms go off they go off
for one of usually about three reasons
of course there's some outside the bell
curve medical issues and all kinds of
bits so don't send me in cards and
letters folks listening but on the whole
anxiety alarms go off when you feel
lonely when your body
looks around and realizes i'm all by
myself
because that also means especially ten
thousand years ago when we were living
in a savannah
if you found yourself by yourself
without your tribe without your
community you're gonna die
right and you could control literally
nothing and that's the second one when
your body feels like it is out of
control both
in its present and its future i don't
know what's coming right
it's the fear of the future and then the
third thing that will spin
spin a body out is when it's not safe
and those work recursively which means
they work in a loop
once you feel unsafe you then look
around to see who's got your back and if
nobody's got your back
then you all of a sudden the alarms get
louder and louder and louder until they
[ __ ] you
and one of the easiest most direct ways
a kid
receives love receives affirmation is
through human touch
and one of the great curses of our time
this is not a
janelle problem you didn't invent this
you didn't do this
and so i'm gonna ask you please don't
walk away from this conversation
beating yourself up okay this is a
worldwide issue that we just told
two-year-old boys to toughen up
and we told two-year-old boys to just go
figure it out
quit crying and get up and
two-year-old boys need direct
touch they need hugs they need eye
contact
just as much as little girls do and they
especially need it from their dads
who are completely ill-equipped to do it
because we didn't get that type of
information because our dads were told
that if they hugged us too much
it was going to make us see the world
differently it was going to make us soft
it's going to make us weak and it's the
exact opposite
when a kid gets deep connection with his
dad
deep connection with his mom then he can
anchor
in deeply and then go out into the world
swinging wild
then go be that adventurous young boy
but without that tethering he is just
flying in the wind there
and so what you just telling me that a
kid loves settling up
and being scratched hey mom will you
just scratch my arms
i would love for you just to give 30
days like it
i would love to from today forward and i
want you to have a hard conversation
with your husband and if he says i'm not
doing that you tell him to call me
okay because i'd love to have a
conversation with him
um but i want both of you to sit with
your son and say we talked to some idiot
on the radio
and he said that we need to start doing
this with you
because we love you more than anything
in the world
and sometimes we show you love by trying
to give you information
trump sometimes we try to show you love
by giving you space
and we learned a new way to show you
that we love you and care about you and
that's through touch
and so we're going to hug you and we're
going to be annoying about it we're
going to be obnoxious about it and
you're going to have to just get over it
because we are going to squeeze hug you
every day
for the next you don't have to give him
30 days it's telling he's going to start
squeeze hugging you
and you're going to get so frustrated by
it and here's what i want you to do
janelle i want you to invite him to sit
by you on the couch
and y'all just watch a show i want you
to hold his hand i want you to put your
arm around him and i want
you to put your hand on the side of his
face or on the back of his neck
and just hold it there for the show
and i want your husband to in the
morning before he goes to work i want
him to grab
your son and hug him and whisper into
his ear
i love you and i'm so glad you're my son
and then when he gets home from work
repeat the same thing
and i want you all to do that for 30
days and here's the deal janelle
i do that every day in my home not
because i'm special because i know the
science
not because i'm special because i'm
trying to change
the legacy of my home and my son
is humongous he is a freak of nature
huge
and he is almost looking me in the eye
already and he's not even 11 years old
and i'm a big guy but every day i'm
hugging him
and i'm making sure he knows that we are
connected in love and he's loved
okay okay this
may not solve all the problems but it
cannot hurt anything it's a great
great place to start
and the last thing i want you guys to do
is i want you and your husband to go see
a marriage counselor together and here's
why
when there is any sort of relational gap
in a marriage when husbands and wives
aren't on the same page
when um people who are
setting the relational example for the
household are not together
and it doesn't have to be bad it doesn't
have to be somebody's having an affair
and somebody's doing this it doesn't
have to be bad
it just has to be a gap if you say
things in your home like well that's
just the way dad is
or hey whoa look out mom's on a whoa
kids feel that space they feel that gap
and they back
fill it with this is my fault and i need
to fix it
and kids cannot handle that
responsibility they're not designed to
handle that responsibility
and every alarm they have sets off and
some alarms set off
and it turns into anxiety and they turn
into a
ball of tension and others go to
perfectionism
i'm just going to be perfect i'm going
to get straight a's i'm going to always
do everything
and parents cheer like we're winning and
then other kids go to
dysfunction i'm going to break things
i'm going to yell i'm going to violate x
y and z so i can get that attention i
can get that connection that i'm craving
i'll take bad connection over no
connection
hear that i will take bad connection
over no connection
and so i want you two guys to go to a
marriage counselor it may be three
sessions and maybe you go three times
and just to make sure y'all are on the
same page
y'all are communicating well the the
less relational attention you'll have
the more you're on the same page
the more your kids alarms can rest and
he can be a child
not somebody who's responsible for the
weight of the house too
and so i've given you a lot there um
janelle thank you so much for that call
and again this is not a conversation
about blame
this is not a conversation about you
should have this is a conversation about
learning something new today
and making a decision to change today so
janelle
30 days of high touch 30 days of hugs
from dad
and i want you to give me a call back
and we're going to do another episode
with you and i want to i want you to let
me know how things are going and if
they're not going well
we'll we'll regroup and we'll go from
there all right let's go to kayla
in louisville kentucky kayla how are we
doing
hi uh i'm doing well how are you i'm
doing good hey
i just need everyone in the world
listening to this to know that i said
louisville instead of louisville i am
learning
and now that i'm here in the south and
i'm practicing and so i'm just
high-fiving myself for that all right so
what's up kayla
i have been um dealing with some
dysfunction in my family
mainly um an issue with my mother
yep hey do me a favor um take a breath
i can already hear it on you and i don't
even know what you're about to ask i can
already hear it on you
um take a big breath take a big breath
and exhale okay
all right i'm with you thank you um
she uses suicide as a manipulation tool
with
me and my family members okay tell me
about us
the most recent one um it wasn't with me
directly
it was with another family member and i
heard it through them
um and was the context um
they are dealing with their relationship
and i'm just being there for them
um but she kind of used it to end the
relate in that conversation
and in that um interaction um
i can't exactly remember the exact
content because i heard it second hand
but it was kind of like
um well i'm just gonna go kill myself
and then she leaves the room um has she
ever
done that has she ever attempted suicide
before or is this just a move
no i believe it's just a move she's used
it
repetitively um i could say probably a
handful of times
over um the years um but i know this
year
and it has gotten progressively
progressively worse
and i think i've just been more aware of
it because i've been listening to your
show
and i've read boundaries and i just want
to know how to
respond this way by still giving her
love and support
sure so first i want to just thank you
for having a
like a just a beautiful heart you're a
good human being
and the world needs more calories in it
because the temptation here is to write
mom off or the temptation here is just
to be a doormat and you are taking the
hard messy right road which is to
navigate all of it
protect your heart protect your mind
protect your family and also love your
mom the best
you can the best she'll allow right so
good for you kayla
um what is your outside of the suicide
threats what is your relationship
like with your mom do y'all go hang out
have coffee together do you see each
other regularly do y'all call once a
week what's it look like
um we're still developing um that
daily interaction i have put it on
myself to kind of reach out to
my parents every week and just kind of
give them a call on the weekend
it's something that i have struggled to
do with in the past and i've recently
just
moved home um so you know moved home in
the same town or moved home back to
their house uh just closer proximity
okay all right and why are you the one
reaching out to them do they not want to
talk to you and they just tolerate you
or do they have other dysfunction going
on in their marriage
yes um i my dad will reach out to me
um i think my mom just struggles with
reaching out
um i know she's going through some
things um i know my parents are going
through things
going through like are they going
through marriage issues they're going
through money issues they're getting
divorced like what are they going
through
um we recently lost a family member
i'm so sorry so i think that's been
hitting them hard yeah
um my sister so oh your sister passed
away recently
yeah two years ago gosh caleb i'm so
sorry
yeah so um our family has gone through
a lot of change yeah that so
sucks i'm so sorry so tell me about your
dad
he's a good guy you love him um he's
good
he's he's strong but he's also going
through
um this past year we've had to be there
for him because he's been going through
some
some mental self challenges he struggles
with
depression and bipolar for for years
um and this year just with the loss of
my sister i think has gotten him
hitting him a lot harder um he's doing
better now
um but i i
yeah so okay so
give me a couple more questions here how
old are you
uh in my 30s okay and do you have
are you married you got kids of your own
i'm married
i don't have any kids no mary no kids
okay
so here's a couple of
things we're gonna start way back and
then we'll get kind of granular okay
number one i want you to get with your
husband if he is
um trustworthy in this way not to say
that he's not trustworthy but that some
people are just good at this and some
aren't
and that's not a knock on him it's just
this is the skill
and if he's not the right one i want you
to get with a couple of girlfriends i
think it'd be good to include him if you
can
even if you say i want you to be a part
of this but i don't want you to say any
words and my wife has done that with me
actually i want you to mourn
the loss of the picture of your parents
okay and i want you to actually own that
the fantasy of and i don't say fantasy
negatively but the picture that you had
of them
walking alongside you as you got older
is going to be very very different and
you don't know what that's going to look
like but it's going to be different
you have a dad who's struggling with
bipolar and deep
deep depression or the loss of his
daughter and
the challenges in his marriage you've
got a mom who's got a lifetime of
connection
and being married to someone bipolar
disorder who lost her daughter
um and all of the
big and little t traumas that go along
with that you just your parents have a
lot on their hearts and minds
and you've got to just put a period at
the end of that sentence
okay yeah and owning that and dropping
your shoulders down
and letting that be truth is gonna hurt
and it's gonna suck
and it's gonna be heavy and it's
something that you got to do
okay okay it may look like writing them
a letter
that says here's what i remember
here's what i wish my childhood would
look like here's what i loved about you
guys
and then ending that letter with the
section on here's who i'm gonna be
in light of the way y'all raised me
here's in light of
the woman i'm growing up to be the wife
i'm growing up to be
here's who i'm going to be and what
you're going to do there is you're going
to acknowledge the good stuff
you're going to nobly acknowledge the
bad stuff
and then you're going to set a
trajectory for where you're headed
okay that's number one number two
is sitting down with your mom if your
dad's got bipolar and he
doesn't take his meds and he's not
willing to be cognitively engaged
it doesn't help to have him a part of
the conversation if he does
if he is like you said doing better he
is taking his medication he's working
hard
working um to do the things he knows he
needs to do to stay well
it would be great to have him a part of
the conversation um
but you have a conversation with both of
them and say and say and you are
full within your right as a child
as an adult to have this conversation
and say mom i cannot have you
threatening suicide ever again
okay that has to stop and let her know
you are wrecking me you're wrecking your
other kids
it hurts us when you threaten we cannot
lose somebody else in this family
if you are struggling mom if you need
help if you don't like our decisions
tell us that
but you cannot threaten suicide anymore
and the or
is this or i will call 9-1-1 every time
and i will tell them that my mom is
threatening to kill herself and she just
hung up the phone on me and she will
answer the phone back and
they will send ambulances and they will
send the whole cavalry
your mom's going to be on the hook
financially for it and she needs to know
that people care about her and do not
play around with that
okay if she says oh honey you know i
would never do that
you know i just say it when i get mad
then that's when you also respond with
that is not acceptable that is not an
acceptable threat that is not an
acceptable joke that's not an acceptable
well i'm just mad i'm gonna start taking
it seriously
every time from this point forward and
let her know i don't have the skills to
handle that
i'm not trained as a psychotherapist i'm
not trained as a medical professional
so i will call 9-1-1 every time
period and letting her know up front
here's how we're going to do that and i
think framing it is
i do not want to lose another family
member i love you guys
yeah and you are well within your right
to draw that boundary
do you feel like you can have that
conversation
um i think it's something that i have
been known that i need to work up
towards
okay and i might have to include um
my husband with that um because i have
a feeling it will not go over well or
it will blow up later okay here's the
thing
it might and all you can control in this
deal is you
right and once you once you draw a
boundary
it's your responsibility to uphold your
in your side of the fence right
and think about it logically and it's
hard to
think about it just facts and figures
wise if somebody says
that's just who i am and a part of being
relationship with me
is accepting that i threaten suicide
every once in a while
right that doesn't sound that doesn't
sound right right
yeah and i know it's your mom and so
backing out of it and hearing it that
way it's like
what no right and owning
both to yourself and to her i don't know
what to do when someone says that so i'm
just calling the people who are trained
um to intervene every time 100 of the
time
and i need you to hear me say what i'm
about to say and this is going to be a
hard thing to hear
and it's going to be a hard thing to say
but i'm going to be honest with you okay
yeah if your mom does go on to hurt
herself
if she does one day take her life that
will not be your fault
do you promise that you hear that from
me yeah
that will not be your fault your
responsibility
is to be honest with your mom to be
loving towards your mom
and to make sure that to the extent that
you can
that medical professionals and emergency
professionals know when she needs help
but if your mom ends up doing that that
will not be on you
okay okay and making that space for
yourself psychologically is important
doesn't sound like she's ever even
attempted it so anything you've told me
so far doesn't make me think that's
imminent
but i always think that's important to
put out there okay
yeah okay so the challenge is going to
be number one
mourning the loss of this picture and
sometimes into our 30s and 40s we
finally go
oh this isn't going to happen right this
isn't going to look like we i thought it
was going to look
and having to sit down and be okay with
that and sometimes that's a that's a
one-hour letter you write it you just
feel a million times better sometimes
it's a process sometimes it takes two or
three people sitting around a campfire
to talk about it
and sometimes it takes a couple of
months with a counselor to work through
it
um but going through the morning process
that your picture is going to look
different
your picture kayla's going to look
different and then
getting the courage getting the space to
have that hard conversation
is going to be critical and if your
husband's going to help that
conversation great
if he's going to complicate it and make
it harder then
maybe he doesn't need to be there but if
he he's going to assist that your mom
would would love to have him there
be there plan this event don't just
spring it on him
and if your dad's in a well space make
sure he's there too
but my heart's with you kayla i know it
sucks i hate that you lost your
sister my i get a sense that you and i
could talk for a while and you've got a
history of some stories you could
probably
just lay out sequentially that would
suggest you've had a tough road to hoe
and i'm i'm heartbroken for you
and i'm also proud of you for making the
hard decision to draw boundaries
to love your mom and still move forward
so good for you kayla
all right let's go to hannah in
minnesota hannah how are we doing
i'm good how are you i'm doing excellent
excellent excellent so how can i help
this morning
uh so me and my husband our
and our daughter are planning on going
to my husband's family for
thanksgiving this year and we recently
found out
that one of my husband's family members
uh is actually a sex offender
and we are just kind of mostly me are
trying to process
you know do we and he would probably be
at thanksgiving and we're trying to
process through
like do we you know suck it up and maybe
be uncomfortable
while we're there or do we not
go and maybe risk um some offense with
his family
you just made me make faces okay so
let's back out a little bit when you say
sex offender
define that for me um
i i don't really know the details but i
know
that um it happened to someone else
in the family so he did it to someone
else in the family
and it was to the extent that
you know he would go to prison for it
is he going to prison has he been to
prison
um he has not and that's kind of um part
of the weird part about it too is that
um
it happened a while like not within the
last
couple years okay last year or something
and um so through the process
you know he actually turned himself in
he's
a christian and he turned himself in um
and he's really gone through this
journey
he told all of his family um but it's
weird because of
covid and everything he went to trial
and the judge actually um
gave him like less than a year of hard
labor instead of you know this is
usually like totally 13 years in prison
because he had really turned a new leaf
and shown
progress and everything but because of
covid he's actually yet to
walk out that sentence so he's still
free basically so he would be and
they're not going to re
look at it until the new year about
really enforcing that because it would
just a lot of details but because of
that he's not in prison so he would be
at family gatherings so i'm going to
answer this
as though it was me i have a four and a
half year old daughter
and a ten-year-old son
so um and i'm going to frame this with i
believe
in redemption for everybody that's the
way i live my life that's the reason i
do this job
as i think there is um a lot of darkness
in the world and i think that
everybody has an opportunity to turn it
around
on any given monday tuesday wednesday i
think you can you can make some
significant changes
if you're willing to do the hard hard
work
that said there is a zero percent chance
i would take my family
in this situation to this thanksgiving
outing
period end of story none
and here's why number one
the obvious is that he will be there but
number two
is it appears that he has a family
rallying around him
that is putting him in situations
that are not wise that are not smart and
that are not safe
and when anybody is coming back from any
sort of darkness
whether it's an affair whether it's
addictions whether it is
um they've they've hurt people like this
in deepened traumatic and profound ways
one of the cornerstones of success is
people around them that keep them
highly accountable who are
basically a fortress for their own
stupidity
their own hurt their own pain and their
own relational needs
and it doesn't appear that he's got that
and so there is a zero percent chance i
would do that
here's why any wise family would look at
this situation
and say there's gonna be a bunch of kids
here and we'd love to have you back and
we're proud of the work you're making no
chance are you coming to this
this is a part of the decisions the part
of the repercussions of decisions that
you
uncle made and it's going to be
years before you are not welcome back in
the family
but that we're going to put you in a
situation with me a bunch of kids
running around here
no chance know-how
and so um you are responsible
and your husband are responsible for
your kids
you can't deal with whatever they're
deciding to do with their family
however insane it is and i'm starting to
get my blood pressure up here
and i don't want that to happen i'm
starting to get fired up a little bit
um and i don't get fired up about a lot
hannah i just don't but this
god almighty this this just pisses me
off um
so you mentioned something in your
original as you were just kind of
talking through this with me and i want
to reframe it for you
you are not going to cause dissension in
the family
by making a decision that you're going
to stay home for thanksgiving and for
christmas
they are
okay and however they frame it however
they spin it however they whatever
they are choosing to not be wise they
are choosing to
ignore they are choosing to um
lean into the hospitality towards a
child molester than they are of their
family members with little kids
and that's just the reality of that
and your husband needs to be the person
that gets up and makes that phone call
that says if uncle so and so is going to
be there we're not going to be there
this year
we will continue to watch his progress
and we will continue to cheer him on as
he grows and heals
but this isn't going to be um our kids
aren't going to be the
the beta test case for if whether he's
well or not
not doing that right and that's just
going to be the way that is
and the way you're saying tells me you
don't think that's going to happen
no i'm just processing it um
because you know me and my husband have
talked about how we want to
handle it going forward and you know
he's you know he's processed through
it and he's you know come to better
terms with it and
you know he's supporting me and whatever
we decide together
and he's okay making those phone calls
and he's you know he said you know
just know like it could do this because
you know his family that is rallied
around uh
this person is saying like he's he's not
dangerous you know he's
you know totally given back his life to
christ
and you know all that stuff and i just
and i'm going to applaud him and i if i
was talking to your husband here on the
phone
i don't want to get between y'all's
marriage but it's it's
not a fair statement for him to put all
of this on to you
and it's not a fair statement for him to
say well and you know what you're gonna
do
i'll make the call but you know what
this is gonna happen
it's not a cool thing man it's not
you all need to be unified in this and
your kids are not the test case for
whether
he has fully come around yet and again i
believe in restoration i believe people
turning over leaves i believe people
growing
and saying sorry i am a product of that
the list of jackassery that i've lived
in my life
and the person i try to become new every
day is happening and happening and
happening right i believe in that
but i'm not gonna my kids are not gonna
be on
the well let's just see we'll trust you
because somebody else trusted him before
and my kids aren't going to be that test
case and
your husband should proudly and with his
head held high
make that call i get the disappointment
but the disappointment should be
that your uncle's family isn't being
more wise
and that your uncle's family is setting
him up to fail they're putting him in a
position
man he's he better he better do right
right he better he better do right
godly dude this is so frustrating man
i hate you're in the situation hannah
this is one of those situations that
should never happen on 20 different
levels
he shouldn't have hurt kids he should
not be walking around
and god almighty his family shouldn't be
like well it's all good
it's all good let's have thanksgiving
let's just put this behind us nope
you don't just put this behind you
you heal from it over a long long period
of time
and i tell you what man i'm keeping my
kids at home
i'm going to have a friend's giving at
home i'm going to invite people over and
we're going to have a blast
but i'm not doing that thank you so much
for the call hannah
well i'm sorry you're in that position
um man get one of those family members
to call me i'd love to talk to them
now i'm sounding like a high school
football player like yeah bro i don't
want to be that guy either
but gosh this pisses me off all right
we're going to end this show we're going
to take a hard right turn
and i'm just going to go straight for a
song lyric that used to bring me a lot
of joy
back in the year 2000 it's when i
graduated college
and there was a really rad band they
stayed mostly underground they had a few
songs that hit kind of big
but they were mostly an underground band
like a college band and i
loved them and they made me laugh and
they brought me joy
and they were they're just fun man and
they came out with a record in 2000
called called let's do it for johnny
the band is bowling for soup and they're
a texas band i love them
in this song sucker punch here's what
they wrote
here she comes again with another
boyfriend she introduces me and says
this is the sweetest guy i've ever known
i can't say a word i never say a word
and she wraps her arms around my neck
and she says you're the sweetest guy
i've ever known
and i say again this is the last time
when you left before i didn't care too
much because i just wish you'd go away
and now i see you and it's just too much
and it takes my breath away
just like a sucker punch and i say again
and i said before and i say once more
this
is the last time it takes my breath away
just
like a sucker punch i love my guys from
bowling pursuit
this has been the dr john doloni show
[Music]
you